*quietly reads* "Use WASD to move, E to interact"
okay...?
*reads* We ask you only to give us a part of you. part of your identity.
OH!
Oh okay
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Mirror Layers!
I was looking for the option menu
Oh
Oh no :(
"I created a new directory in your Documents folder that collects informations about your personality" ?!
I don't know if I consented to that -_-
Oh
So please, Share them with the world. Some tasks need Real cooperation to be solved. Use the computer if you need help. Don't be shy.
I don't knuh-
I don't know if you're gonna give me the option of being shy or not.
hai :3
Welcome to this game!
I didn't know that I was starting already.
So.
This is Mirror Layers!
And.
Supposedly.
This is a game that messes with you...
And now I'm starting to see why, and-
Ooh.
And how.
Oh geez ...
Oh,
no
oh,
n-
OH!!!
Oh I did! :D
So hello, welcome to Mirror Layers!
I'm actually gonna hit play now,
Oh...
Okay.
Alright.
So, supposedly this is a game that messes with you, and-
It creep-
Wait.
Hang on, before I even get started here, I gotta see.
There's a message in my-
This is the game folder.
Oh, OH-
There it is! :3
statue_input.
Ohh.
statue_output!
OHH BOI!
OH OKAY.
Alright then.
Thanks, buddy.
Oh, I'm so happy about this. :D
Oh no.
Oooh no.
Ooooooh noooo. *Nervous laugh/cry*
Okay.
Oh geez.
Command list: Help
So I have to-- Oh.
OOOOOH!
OOOH BOY.
This is literally a public group about Mirror Layers
"I finished it, it was amazing."
"I really like the way the computer in the game  affects my real computer in real life." *Laugh*
"When I type documents into the prompt in the game it opens up files on my computer."
What?!
"When type in help it brings me to this page."
Ooooh nooo. *nervous laughter*
"Tape that says dad."
"FOR WHOEVER NEEDS IT?!"
WHAT?!
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?!
Oh no... "Does anybody have key 2? I have key 3..."
*laughs nervously* Oooh no...
Oh my god.
That's amazing.. :O
That's amazing! :D
I don't remember my-
>dir
Type in "dir"
Oh- Yeah, it goes in the Documents folder.
Holy shit!
Oh my god, hahaha, that's so cool!
Oh okay and also moderately terrifying. So-
I think I've prefaced everything that I needed to preface in this game
It's basically a game that just dicks with you the whole time.
Is that- That is actually what time it is.
In my real life here
So-
Oh that's so bizarre.
Oh that's so weird.
Okay ... Do I hear a drippy droppy?
Okay I just hear a lot of tick-tocking.
And then I don't know what else is going on.
Oh boy, oh boy...
Oh, nice shoes.
*Door creaks*
(What the shit.)
Hi? Ok...hello? Hi! How are you?
Oh, you have boobs! And no arms and no face.
A connection between this world and the one you're living in.
Ohh. *laughs* Oh, oh ok, alright then.
Oh no, oh no...
...The fuck was that?
I'm hearing a lot of noises for being here.
Hopefully by myself.
Can I knife someone?
Can I pick up the knife, can I--
*door closes*
*SLIENCE*
*STILL QUIET*
...Was that me?
Was that me?
That wasn't me.. I was just trying to pick up a broom D:
*Mark cries*
Oh no...
Oh god no. :c
Okay, so it seems okay so far.
oh boy, oh boy, oh boy
OH it's a dead end!
OH I just have a dead end in my house
Don't worry about me
hello- oh I thought you were cthulhu
oh boy...
oooh boy, oh boy. oh boy, oh boy, oh boy.
oh boy, okay so I need to have a bit more
intelligent commentary than just "oh boy"
why do I have no reflec-
*static noises*
HIII
HI.
HELLO!
ohh no. okay, are you dead?
you better be dead!
I hope you're dead!
I mean that's a weird thing for me to say but
you know what, I just, oh geez
Oh geez scoob.
oh hello hi
oh oh it's a mirror world. I get it.
I can't use this computer, this computers off
*Mark cries*
am I alone here?
that's the biggest question on my mind
what the hell is that
*Mark yells*
*Mark yells again*
DON'T LIKE IT.
oh god, oh god...
oh god, what is this
hello
CAN I HAVE THESE
Ugh
hello! four...
I don't know
hello thank you, i have- i got a 4!
are there four boxes?
oh geez... fucking stop
JUST STOP!
*mutters*
okay so I i found the 4 box-
oh god these clocks are all WRONG
that's not my time
time doesn't exist in this place
oh what's that?
I got a 2!
*creepy noises*
THE FU-- I'M SORRY
THE FUCK IS THAT?!
Ehh *scared*
Ehhhh :(
OH HI! You're not the Grim Reaper or Cthulhu!
oh boy oh HEY oh fuck god damn it
fucking asshole
*scary noises*
WHAT IS THAT
HEY what is that
*scary noises continue*
IS THAT OR IS THAT NOT A THING
I NEED TO KNOW...RIGHT NOW
oh fuck dude...what is that
*SCARY MUSIC*
AH FUCKING, WHAT THE FUCK!?
OH MY GOD
*suavely wipes spit from face*
*Puh*
:O
ok alright everything's fine.
I spat a lot more than I intended to
and also I expected today to be a day
where my voice could recover
I haven't even talked to you guys this whole time
I've been a bit preoccupied with not dying
oh ho ho ho ah ha euhaha-- oh god what's on my screen
oh no, oh geez can I put this-
oh there we go we go, okay
oh ok you're just gonna ignore
all the random text on my screen
oh noooo, heeelp me. :'(
oh geez
oh no
oh man, what does that mean
"Does anybody have key 2?"
I have key 2!
...ohhh... *lightbulb!*
ohhh, I get it!
I get it!
"Does anybody have key 2, I have key 3."
I have key 2, I have box 4!
I need key 4!
I have key 2!
ooooh man!
oh that's so crazy
How do I give them key 2?
How do I /give/ key 2?
I have- oh wait, "All keys here, key 2 is lolliness.mirror"
That's a bit risky, clicking on a random download link
I'll do it though :D
I'll do it for you guys cus I love you!
let me let me do a little antivirus
you know, protection.
If you're going to be playing this game,
and I highly recommend you do,
definitely watch what you download.
Be very careful out there.
scan it before you open it, all that stuff.
oh no, what does "frasi" mean??
please- oh god-
"Please let me live near your world
I only want to"
*Mark cries* I don't know what that means!
I don't know what that means :(
but i need key four
So I put this in input?
Is that the sound of something crawling
through one of my mirrors?!
or is that good?!
So if the statue...
*witnesses black magic*
O-oh oh my god oh m- I
didn't even restart my game!
oh my god
"A connection between this world and the one you're in"
That makes so much sense!
That's so cool! That's ludicrously cool!
What the hell!?
So if i put wait I have an idea if I put
my key but if I throw it in the statute...
Transferred to your world?
What!?
OOOOHHH OH MY GOD
It's there!
What??! ....................................................... That's so cool
Oh man, I'm losing my voice already. Oh my
god that is the coolest. That is that is
one of the most unique things I've ever
seen in a game; let alone a horror game
but, now the problem is I have to go back *pause*
into the mirror ohh nooo I don't wanna :(
I don't have a reflection, but the key do
Ehh x3
why am I here why am I here
okay I'm just gonna put in the box Oh
God
hello hi do--    I am I staring in the face
of death? Eugh... uh... okay... here we go
Oh. Wh-what! Why do I have a leg?
Why do I have a leg!? Oh Long Leg Larry
we're gonna go on a fucked-up adventure
Long Leg Larry. I have a funny feeling I
know who owns you
oh don't worry I'm gonna adopt you Long
Leg Larry. Look out for the next charity
stream we got the exclusive plushie for
a Long Leg Larry. Oh God. Uh.
I'm pressing "E". You want it or not? Oh
fucking god damn it...
okay o.o oh...OH! All is good! Is that the end of the
game. Did I do it? Is that all I
needed to do that couldn't have been all
I needed to do...
oh no oh no oh no oh no...
oh no...
I gotta go back don't I?
*sounds of static and electricity*
Oh no.
Oh boy.
Did I hear a dog barking?
Okay so Larry's gone.
So...
Let's see here...
Ah Hi
oh boy hi oh hi
how are you doing
oh ho ho oh no
okay you know what okay so you're
missing an arm
I have a funny feeling I know how
this is gonna go.
What is this?
Oh it's
a code board
oh no that means that other people are
going to have the code but
I don't have the code.
Ok so it's a four character code
*eugh* Hi. So there's gotta be... There's got
to be something in here that I have
*Eugh*
that other people do not have
That's got to be the thing right
that's how this works so if i have.... if- or
if I if I have something that I'm-
THE FUCK IS THAT?! D:
OHMYGOD
OOOOOoooh FUCK OFF
*sounds of static and electricity*
oh man my voice is not going to keep up
through this oh no D: i do not know what that
was but it was different than the other one
i don't want to know but I'm going back.
I'm a brave boy (sure Mark)
I'm a big brave boy
(totally)
God ok so... Ah of
course I should go back here
*eugh* geez. I should go back here to where...
ok so there's nothing here anymore so
it's not here unless it's here... (what Mark?)
That's got to be like a code written on the
walls or maybe on the computer.
Hang on one second.
On the computer!
no :c (Mark's dreams are crushed)
oh what's that
father father *friendly voice* and welcome boys and girls *static* we are live for the in twelve minutes broadcast
oh D! *pfft* OH D! I don't have anything to write down with something to write down with d ok i'll remember (Sure you will)
d-d-DDDDDDDDDDDDDD
I get it d d what- what does that mean??????
are there more tapes in here? I've got a D ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
but that doesn't help me unless it's
like I've got one letter and maybe I
need to submit that it's apparently....
either fifty- ah fuck-OH FUCKING OH GOD OH FUCKING GOD
NONONONONONONO
BRAUHUHUHHH FUCK OFF *girlish scream* oh fucking god damn it
*sigh of exasperation* oh ok so what I'm getting out of this
fuck is that I'm probably gonna go die
the next time I go in there
but I've got a D ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
so what I think needs to happen
is i actually need you guys help on this
one I I'm gonna end this episode here
i'm actually out of time but what I need
you guys to do is: I need you to play
this game with me I legitimately need
you guys to play this game with me
because this is fucking incredible like
this is actually legitimately
mind-blowing right now this is so cool
so I'm going to link to the description- uh..
in the description to the game where you can
download it i just remember like I said
when you're sharing files be very
careful don't
download just anything always scan with
your antivirus before you open it but
just... this is cool and I need you guys
help with this one because I literally
cannot finish this game by myself
also my voice may not keep up with me
but let me know what you think down the
comments below let me know in find down
the comments below and I'm gonna get out
of here before I somehow die because I
have a I have a sneaking suspicion that
the longer i play in this area i might
dies while here so thank you everybody
so much for watching I look forward to
your input on this very soon and as
always I will see you in the next video
buh bye :D